Hello, my name is
Dr. Adam Hurst. I'm a
general pediatrician
with the Clinical
Medicine Department
here with a lecture on
neurodevelopmental and
behavioral problems
in children and for
school dysfunction. so
objectives here compare
and contrast the
diagnostic features for
speech delay communication
disorders and autism
spectrum disorder
providing a differential
diagnosis workup
and management for each
defining intellectual
disability along with
potential causes and
the workup for a
child with a suspected
intellectual disability
comparing and contrasting
chronic tick disorder
and Tourette syndrome
explaining the
definition of learning
disorder while describing
the important elements
of the history and
workup for a child with
a suspected learning
disorder, comparing
and contrasting oppositional
defiant disorder
and conduct disorder,
and outlining the
elements of a history
that are important for
a child presenting with
a behavior problem.
Here's just an overall
outline for the lecture.
Initially we'll
just go over general
developmental
delays, then
communication and
language disorders,
autism spectrum
disorder, intellectual
disability, motor disorders,
which would include
chronic disorder and
Tourette's syndrome,
learning disorders,
and behavior problems.
So this chart here
just being able to show
the prevalence of
developmental and
behavioral problems
in comparison to other
chronic medical
conditions in children and
can see that only
asthma is anywhere
close to having the
prevalence of other
neurodevelopmental and
behavioral problems.
This is a breakdown
of children 3 to
21 years of age
that are listed as
receiving disability
through the Individuals
with Disabilities
and Education Act.
And we can see that
approximately 30%
have a specific
learning disability, 20%
have a speech and
language impairment,
13% with autism, 7
% having a general
developmental disability,
delay and so a good
breakdown of these
conditions and so for the
first kind of half of
the learning centered
around this patient
in this patient case
and so you have a 24
month old male come
into your office for
a well visit the mom
has concerns that he's
not saying as many
words as his sibling
does and has frequent
tantrums birth
history is notable for
prematurity at 34 weeks
of gestation and there
is a family history
the father had learning
problems and an older
sibling has ADHD.
Your exam has normal
growth parameters and
a normal physical
exam and while you're
in the room you kind of
note that the patient
makes really bad
eye contact at times
really doesn't respond
his name and the only
thing that you hear
the child say is no.
The child's fixated
on playing with
the car and at
one point when the
mom takes it away
after asking several
times to stop
playing with it the
child throws a
very large tantrum.
So pause for a second
and try to write out
a differential diagnosis
having like three
diagnoses and put your
most likely first.
So the differential
for this patient
I have an expressive
speech delay,
communication or
language disorder,
hearing loss,
autism spectrum disorder,
or an intellectual
disability. And
now Now often this
group of disorders
will always be your
differential for a
similar presentation.
And so as hold on to this
differential diagnosis
because these
are the things
we'll walk through
for this patient
and these disorders.
And so first
understanding
what is a
developmental delay.
Developmental
milestones are the
neurodevelopmental
laws, the things most
children can do by
certain specific age.
These are the
sequences that provide
the framework for
observing and monitoring
a child's development
over time.
Now, when a child
is outside of that
range of normal
variation, that's where
you say it's a delay
in development.
Developmental
delays can be
isolated, so it
can only be for one
area, whether it's
motor, speech,
cognitive, or
social, or it can
involve more than
one. A global delay
would involve
having more than at
least two domains
being delayed.
And now, the important
point to understand
is the difference
between an delay
and a disorder,
and that relates to
the degree of
impairment and function.
So how much is it
impacting their day.
And so it being such
a wide variation in
what's considered normal
within the various
domains of speech fine
motor gross motor the
main thing you come
across as a pediatrician
or the general
provider is when do you
monitor closely and
when do you move forward
with further workup
and often just close
monitoring is
appropriate and providing
anticipatory
guidance instructions
to the parents
of what to watch for
and what to encourage
however if red flags
are present you have to
proceed with a
further workup and you
shouldn't delay and this
breaks down a few of the
general categories of
like gross motor red
flags of an inability
to sit at nine months
would warrant further
evaluation and
testing. Cognitive red
flags, an inability to
turn to sound or voice
at six months of age.
If they are lacking
in single words
at 15 months
already initiating
further kind of
testing and evaluation.
The main point to
really take home though
is a loss of milestones.
It's always a
red flag and so if a
child had developed a
skill or developed a
word or a phrase or
these abilities and
now they lose those,
I mean a major red
flag to work up
as correlated with
genetic conditions
or other underlying
etiologies.
Now Now the management
of a developmental
delay is to
intervene, and
that's the key
concept because early
intervention can
show great progress
and response to
the area of delay.
And that's referring
to the appropriate
service, whether
it's speech therapy
for a speech or
language delay, physical
therapy for gross
motor delay, or
occupational therapy
for a fine motor delay.
You might also need to
refer to a subspecialist,
whether that's a
geneticist or neurology
or even a developmental
pediatrician.
You're also there
as a support and
education for
parents and to be a
medical home and
that's where you can
help assist in
keeping track of
referrals and specialist
recommendations
and you're in that
position to help the
parent understand the
overall plan and make
sure that all their
needs are being met.
So now moving into
kind of communication
disorders. And so
for a speech and
language development,
that being an early
marker of cognitive
development. And so
for a language
disorder, it's a delay
or deficit in the
comprehension or production
in language
that's significant
enough to cause
impairment in functioning.
So delay does not
necessarily mean
disorder, it's again
looking at the function.
And so it's important
to understand,
is this causing an
impact in their day?
Now, these delays
are often associated
with comorbidities
and learning
problems or
behavior problems.
And really having that
exposure to
speech matters.
The more the child hears,
the more they will learn.
So constantly
reminding the parents
to talk and read
to their patient.
Now, screening tools
cannot predict if a
language delay will
be persistent or not.
However, they can
catch early issues.
And now there are a
few urban myths that
you would hear for why
some children might
not be talking at their
normal age, and whether
that's because
they're in a bilingual
household or they have
older siblings that
talk for them, but
those would not be true.
Children should be
expressing similar sounds
and words and phrases
regardless whether
they're in a bilingual
household or they
have older siblings
that talk for them and
so right now we'll
kind of go over about
four main disorders
understanding to about
five to eight percent
of children how to
speech language delay
by the preschool years
so we'll walk
through these four
disorders language
disorder and so a
persistent difficulty
in the comprehension
and or production
of language. It
results in functional
limitations.
Usually presents as
reduced vocabulary,
limited sentence
structure or limited
conversation skills,
deficits having issues
with that spoken
communication and or
written communication
or sign language.
Usually presents as
a delay in onset of
words up to three years
of age or, again, that
reduced vocabulary or
sentence abilities.
Deficits are not due
to hearing impairment
or due to environmental
deprivation
or an underlying
medical condition,
so you would need
to rule those out.
And oftentimes the
child compensates for
their inability to use
words by using gestures
or other body
languages, but often the
child becomes frustrated
or tantrums result.
And you can have
both receptive and or
expressive language
could be delayed.
The next one being a
speech sound disorder.
So this is a persistent
difficulty with
speech and sound
production that interferes
with speech
intelligibility or prevents
verbal communication.
And so the
articulation of the speech
sound is impaired to
the point that they
cannot communicate.
And this can be
very frustrating,
not only for the
patient, because
they can't express
themselves, but also
for the parent
or the caregiver.
And so as a
stranger, at the
age of 2, I should
understand 50
% of what a child
should say.
At the age of 3, I
should understand
75% of what a
child should say.
At the age of 4, I should
be able to understand
100% of what that
child should say.
And so if they are five
and I can only understand
50% of what they're
saying, the concern
would be having a
speech sound disorder.
And now, speech sound
disorder and language
disorder, both can
respond very well
to speech therapy
after it's initiated.
Next being a child
onset fluency
disorder. And
this being in
reference to,
like, stuttering.
And so clinically,
it's a significant
impairment in speech
fluency and timing. And
it affects 1% of school
-aged children and
can be three times
more common in boys.
And again, having
the symptoms of poor
fluency, poor timing,
and needing a speech
therapist and needing
further evaluation.
And the last one
that we'll talk about
is for social
pragmatic communication
disorder. And that's
an impairment in the
use of language for
social exchanges.
Impairment in the
ability to adapt
communication styles to
context or interactions,
or having issues
following conventional
and cultural norms
for conversation, and
inability to understand
ambiguous languages.
And so this child has
difficulty interpreting
what they're saying
and do, expressing
themselves verbally or
non-verbally. They don't
understand humor or
sarcasm appropriately.
It often leads to
difficulty in school, and
so then they get bullied
or ostracized and
will have emotional
problems, conduct issues.
And it's important
to differentiate this
from autism, and so
autistic children do
not want that social
interaction, whereas
these kids with a
social communication
disorder are searching
for that social
interaction, they
just have trouble
achieving it. And so
commonly, we'll need
both speech therapy and
social skills therapy
to help and improve
those abilities.
So now for the
workup and management
of a speech and
language disorder,
starting first with
the history and
physical exam. And
so that would include
both your prenatal
and birth history,
and so looking
into complications,
any inter utero
infections or exposures,
along with any family
history of other
speech or language
disorders. Also, a very
comprehensive physical
exam looking at growth
parameters and for any
dysmorphic features
that could suggest
a genetic or
underlying reason for
their language disorder.
Next would be to
assess the hearing. And
so all newborns
will have a newborn
hearing screen, but
if they present at six
months of age with
speech or language
concerns, you still
need to refer and do
a formal hearing assessment
by an audiologist
to ensure that that's
not the reason,
despite that normal
hearing screen.
Depending on what
you have found as
your screen of,
hey, I'm a general
pediatrician out in
my office and they
have areas of
delay or disorders,
then I will refer
to a speech language
speech therapist for a
speech language
evaluation.
And that's going to
be more in-depth,
looking at very
specifics and
helping to determine
the level and the
degree of the delay
or the disorder.
Also for me as
the pediatrician
or the general provider,
ruling out any
other underlying
disorders and so is
there a genetic disorder,
do they have autism,
is there a global
delay or more areas of
developmental delay.
Referring to speech
therapists when
indicated, so if the
child is less than 3 years
of age, referring to
early intervention
or if they're older
than three whether
it's preschool or a
school that can do
it or through a private
speech therapist.
Also important to
educate the parents.
What are the
goals? How can
they work with the
child at home reading
and talking to
their children?
So that finishes the
work up and kind of the
plan for a speech and
language disorder.
Moving into Autism
Spectrum Disorder, so this
is a lifelong
neurodevelopmental disorder
associated with deficits
in social communication
and social interaction,
and it's accompanied
by restrictive or
repetitive behaviors.
And the prevalence
has been increasing,
so in 2000 it was
1 in 150 children,
whereas in 2010, 1 in 68,
1 in 54 children in
2016, and most recent
data in 2020 showing
1 in 36 children
being diagnosed
with Autism Spectrum
Disorder, and males
being more common
than females in a
4-1 ratio, that's
having a very increased
prevalence and
being able to understand
and help these
children and adults
with this disorder.
And so for risk
for Autism Spectrum
Disorder, kind of
going at it from both
the genetics and a
biological approach
to risk. So risk
being if there's a
genetic problem. So
chromosomal disorder,
fragile X being
the most common,
also associated with
Down syndrome or
Rett syndrome or
tubular sclerosis.
And a known genetic or
chromosomal condition
is identified in
approximately 10 to
15 people with autism
spectrum disorder.
Then looking too at
genetics is the heredity
and having an
increased prevalence in
siblings up to almost a
25% chance of a second
child having Autism
Spectrum Disorder.
When you think about
a biological risk,
having older
parents, having
any prenatal exposures,
especially ones
that would have
a neurologic
insult, so alcohol,
your CNS, torch
infections,
any drugs or
heavy metals, also
associated with
prematurity or low birth
weight for biological
risk factors.
And one that has
definitely been
disproven, however,
still is one
discussed by patients
or families, is
that vaccines do
not cause autism.
So when you look at
the autism spectrum
disorder, having two
kind of core dimensions,
the social and the non
-social, and so focusing
on these two core
areas, they have a
lack of social interest
and for those with
social difficulties are
due to problems with
their ability to
communicate and each of
these core will have
a few more details as
we'll go through also
important to kind of
remember previously this
was referred to as a
pervasive developmental
delay and Asperger's
disorder birth syndrome
could have been
used however right
now everything is now
referred to as autism
spectrum disorder and kind
of those previous
terms are now falling
under the umbrella of
autism spectrum disorder
and there's now a
focus of the severity
So now looking at the
diagnostic features
of autism, and so
having deficits
in social communication
and social
interaction, and so
they have difficulty
with that back and
forth conversation.
They might also have
language regression,
or they have
reduced sharing of
interests and emotions,
and so definitely
have that limited
joint attention.
You'll have a child
who doesn't want to
show any toys to their
parents, or doesn't
want to show them
what they've been
playing with. These
children also have
difficulty with empathy,
difficulty initiating
or responding to
social interactions,
being those social
-emotional issues
they have.
Autistic will also
have areas for
nonverbal
communication problems,
so they have poor
eye contact. They
don't laugh or
they don't point.
And so that being a big
sign for some toddlers
is to point and show
their parents what
they've seen or what
they want to have for
a meal or a snack and
they aren't pointing.
They have deficits
of facial expression.
They also lack that
social smile to others.
And then the third
area, having issues
with developing,
maintaining, or
understanding
relationships. And so just
difficulty adjusting
for those behaviors,
having issues with
shared and imaginative
play, have issues
making friends
and showing interest
in their peers.
And from the
social categories,
they need at
least one area
that they're
having issues in.
And then from
a restrictive,
repetitive behaviors
or interest,
needing at least
two of these
four non-social
categories.
And so seeing that
they have stereotypical
or repetitive movements,
they line up their
toys or they have
idiosyncratic phrases.
Echolalia is
commonly associated
with autism
spectrum disorder.
They also will have
an insistence on the
sameness and have
that very specific
routine that if it
gets broken will lead
to a very large
tantrum. They get
extremely distressed
by minute small changes
or have difficulty
with transitions.
Also have restricted
interests and
only focus on
specific the same
specific things
and sometimes very
preoccupied with
unusual objects.
And then you
have a hyper or
hyporeactivity to
sensory input and so
indifference to
pain or temperature,
excessive smelling
or touching of
objects,
sometimes a visual
fascination with
lights or movements.
And so to help with
that diagnosis, they
need at least one
symptom from each of the
social categories, and
they need at least one
symptom from two of
the four non-social
categories. I'm sorry,
I might have misspoke,
but need at least one
symptom from the social
category, and need
at least one symptom
from two of the four
non-social categories.
And now these
symptoms have to
be present in
early development
and cause significant
impairment.
And it's also
important to note that
cognitive
development, that most
individuals with autism
have intellectual
abilities in the
normal range.
So they have a normal IQ.
So that would not
be a reason for
some of their
behaviors or symptoms.
Now early symptoms of
autism, we talked on
some of these and I
think the important
thing to see here is
there's a lot of links
and these will take
you to videos from CDC
that show examples and
so click through and
kind of have an
understanding of having
that lack of eye contact
and how that looks
in clinic. that lack
of joint attention. So
showing areas that
they are lacking in
social interaction for
their delay in language
development, not
having social battling,
having language
regression,
echolalia,
limited imaginative
play, or
atypical
mannerisms as well.
So with diagnosing
autism spectrum disorder,
early diagnosis
intervention is optimal,
just like our
speech and language
disorders, getting
a great history
and also a good
physical exam while
assessing for
hearing and vision
and ensuring no
comorbid conditions.
And now screen tools
from a *** standpoint
are very important.
There are some
checklists early on,
but the one to remember
is that in chat.
So it's commonly
completed at 18 and
24 months of age and
sometimes can repeat
it at 30 months of age.
And that's the main
one to know. And
now when you need
to refer, so it's
indicated based upon
your MCHAT or your
screening tools,
you're getting an in
-depth evaluation
by a developmental
pediatrician and a
multidisciplinary team.
Now this team might
involve a child
psychologist, the speech
-language pathologist, a
child psychiatrists,
education specialists.
And unfortunately,
sometimes this
in-depth
evaluation can take
months or a year
until it's done.
The important thing
to remember is don't
delay your management
steps while awaiting this
evaluation and formal
diagnosis. Refer to
the appropriate services
as soon as you can.
Get them set up with
speech therapy for
speech delay or language
issues. Get them
set up with occupational
therapy if they're
having issues with
any five-monther,
social therapy to assist
and help with skills.
Don't wait on that
formal evaluation.
When we started
talking about this,
but the management
of autism is where
they're getting their
therapy and their
support, and
specifically having
educational and
behavioral interventions.
You'll have applied
behavioral analysis,
so that's more heard
as ABA. So ABA helps
that child understand
a specific behavior.
And they look at
replacing problematic
behaviors with a more
functional one. And
so they're working
on specific goals and
specific adjustments
for that patient.
Whether they're
getting speech therapy,
whether they have
functional communication
assistance, and so
whether that's through
the use of devices
or pictures, tablets,
if occupational
therapy or
social skills
support is helpful.
And in thinking of the
management, also if
a medication is indicated.
And now there's no
specific medicine for
autism. However, if
they have a comorbid
condition or symptom,
can a medication assist
with that? Whether
they have ADHD, sleeping
issues, anxiety, are
there medicines that
can help them? And then
you're just kind of
continuing to do what
we've talked about,
educating, supporting the
family, being that
medical home for them.
Here's a good
breakdown for speech
disorders versus autism
spectrum disorder.
and it does kind of
mention that this
specific language
impairment, the SLI, is in
place of kind of the
language disorder
that we discussed
earlier and so can show
kind of a breakdown
between these areas.
I think one of the
major distinctions lie
in the social and
imaginative behaviors.
Children with a speech
-language disorder
have that social drive,
but that children
with autism spectrum
disorder they
lack. Children with
a speech language
disorder are capable
of joint attention,
exhibit imitative
and pretend play.
They don't exhibit
the restrictive
repetitive behaviors
or interests that
are seen in autism
spectrum disorder.
Now we move on to
intellectual disability
and previously known
as mental retardation.
And so, for
intellectual disability,
that's that combination
of impairment
of cognitive and
adaptive development.
And now, the more
severe the intellectual
disability, the
earlier it's
typically recognized
and diagnosed.
And those with mild ID
may not be diagnosed
until school for
several years, depending
on how severe it could
be. And that's why
intellectual disability
needs to be on a
differential diagnosis
for children presenting
with various
developmental problems.
And now the clinical
presentation
varies a lot
and usually that
begins with delays
in development.
Gross motor delay
is usually within
normal limits.
It's the receptive
language delays that
are more common.
And so for cognitive
development having
that reduced IQ and
again having a wide
range of the severity.
For your adaptive
development, now
we're talking about
deficits in function.
So how are they
conceptualizing, so
their language, their
reading, their writing
abilities, social skills,
are they problem
-solving, are they making
friends, and then
their practical skills,
their activities of daily
living, their personal
care, as they get older,
are they beginning
to have deficits in
any of those areas.
Now for the common
causes of intellectual
disability, and there's
a good breakdown of
a list over here,
prenatal and genetic is
the most common
causes, with Fragile X,
Trisomy 21 being common
genetic abnormalities,
inter-utero
infections, so that
being like your
torch infections,
also for fetal alcohol
spectrum disorder,
and that being the
most common cause
of preventable
intellectual disability.
But unfortunately, often
no cause is identified.
And now for the workup
for an intellectual
disability, you
have the history.
Now your goal as
the physician is
really to ensure
nothing else is
there to work up
or to rule out in
your patient. So
with your history,
you're again
checking your
prenatal or
perinatal events. So
was their pregnancy
complicated?
Was the birth
Do they have a past
medical history of
any chronic disorders,
any family history
of other family
members having similar
issues, and then also
getting a very good
behavioral and
developmental history.
Did they have
any delays? Have
they received
any therapies?
Next would be the
physical exam, and so
looking at their overall
growth parameters,
any dysmorphic
features on their skin
or neurologic exam,
and just like in
our speech and
language area, ensuring
that their vision and
hearing are normal.
The next step
would be lab tests,
and that's really
only if it's
indicated on the
history and physical.
You also can review
their newborn
screen that
will look into
genetic or other
abnormalities.
But the genetic testing,
it's very specific,
and it's really just
a rule out. it's
not that common in
the case of a general
pediatrician. This is
the specialist that
might be looking at
specific disorders.
And it is important
to note that a
normal physical
exam does not rule
out an underlying
genetic cause.
Now, it could cause
almost like 14% of
children that have a
non-diagnostic history
in physical could
have this underlying
genetic etiology,
that being associated
with like maybe a
fragile X, or found after
they've done a
chromosomal microarray.
Also talking about
the neuroimaging,
really only if
your history
and physical suggest it,
and most commonly
it's going to
be an MRI as the
test of choice.
And this again
is looking into,
is there another
reason for their
intellectual disability
for their symptoms.
Now you can get into
the assessment of the
cognition and their
adaptive functioning.
And in the notes
section, there's going to
be a breakdown of
what these tests are.
You don't need to know
the specific names.
Commonly these are
going to be done by
that psychologist and
helping break down
their very specific
symptoms and how much
of an impact it's
having on their day.
So now for the
management,
I kind of broke it
down into who is
first. And so this is
a multidisciplinary
team. So you as
the physician,
your subspecialist,
the psychologist,
your therapist,
whether it's an
occupational or a
speech therapist,
an audiologist,
your teacher,
children with intellectual
disabilities have
a team working with
them and helping them.
And it's also good to
know is the how. And
so we have the Individuals
for Disabilities
Education Act, and that
requires all states
that receive federal
funds for education to
provide free and
appropriate public education
for all individuals
3 to 21 years of age.
And with that, you get
educational inclusion.
And so the goal being
the least restrictive
educational environment
as possible. The
child should be in the
mainstream classroom
as much as their
individualized education
plan allows, as much
as the child allows.
And that could
be a whole lot
or a whole little
depending on
the child, but
they have the
safety within
the system to be
around others and
to be encouraged
to be with their
classmates.
They also get an
IEP, and so that's an
individualized
education plan. and so
a lot of educational
supports working
for these students
and these children.
Now the overall goal
is for those with an
intellectual disability
is to prepare them
for employment, to
help them build skills,
help them have the
best quality of life,
and some may not achieve
full independence,
but they might be
able to meet specific
goals, and that's where
that specific educational
plan comes into play
of are we working
on communication skills,
self-help skills,
what job could I have as
I continue to get older.
So moving over to
motor disorders,
briefly touching on them.
So you have our
developmental coordination
disorders, stereotypical
movement disorders,
Tourette's
syndrome, and a
persistent or
chronic tic disorder.
Now that developmental
coordination
disorder, that's
just a issue with
execution of coordinated
motor skills.
So these are the children
that are extremely
clumsy, are very
slow or inaccurate
with those motor
skills. They can't use
scissors well. They
don't know how to ride
a bike. They don't
participate in sports.
In children with
stereotypical movement
disorders, these
are repetitive
movements, purposeless
motor behaviors.
So whether that's the
handshaking or body
rocking, head *******,
it could be injurious.
It may not always
be self-injurious.
but any more on
Tourette syndrome and so
Tourette's being both
motor and one or more
vocal tics and so if
you talk about a tick so
that's a sudden brief
intermittent movement
whether it's motor or
vocal it's involuntary
but it sometimes
can be voluntarily
suppressed and so for a
motor tic having an eye
blinking or facial
grimacing, head jerking,
versus a vocal tic,
so grunting, clearing
of the throat, repetition
of words, being
those two differences.
But for Tourette's being
multiple motor and one
or more vocal tics.
That's been present
for at least a year.
That being different
than a persistent
or chronic tic
disorder, which is
just a motor or a
vocal tic, not both.
Now, these motor
disorders, it more
impacts their life,
and so they have normal
delay, they don't
have any other delays
and have normal
gross and fine motor
abilities. However,
this motor disorder
impacts their day-to
-day life and their
activities of daily
living because of
this tick that they
have no control over.
So we'll move back to
our first patient case.
And so again,
this was our
24-month-old X34 weaker.
Has very few
words, frequent
tantrums, and
poor eye contact.
And so you did an ages
and stages questionnaire
that looked at all
their development,
and they got a delay
in communication. So
you also had the parent
perform an MCHAP that
was not concerning
for autism spectrum
disorder because, hey,
on further evaluation,
the concerns she had,
there was nothing
consistent with autism
spectrum. And so
this patient was
referred for audiology
testing and a formal
speech evaluation.
The hearing testing
revealed bilateral
hearing loss, and the
speech and language
evaluation conferred
your speech delay.
and EMT further
evaluated for and added
hearing aids and speech
therapy was initiated
and at 30 months
he had demonstrated
improvement but now
we move on to our next
patient and so this
is a seven-year-old
male that's in second
grade came in because
of school problems
he was born at 37
seven weeks, has a
past medical history
that got speech therapy
for speech delay,
has a family history
notable for a father
with ADHD and siblings
with learning problems,
and has several
stressors on a social
history, and so the
parents divorced last year
and his grandmother
recently passed away.
And so on your
questioning of your school
problems, this
little man is getting
poor grades, is
having Cs, Ds, and Fs.
His teacher most
recently recommended
he repeat the grade,
and for the last
few months has just
been getting in trouble
in school, talking
back, won't sit
in his seat, fighting
with his friends.
So again, pause
for a second,
list out a
differential diagnosis,
put your most
suspected one first.
And so here's our
differential for our
second patient, mental
learning disorder,
behavior disorder,
ADHD,
intellectual disability,
mood disorder, or just
related to the stressors.
And similar to our
other patient, this
differential diagnosis
is very common in
children presenting
with school dysfunction.
And so we'll kind
of walk through
our final two
outline points here.
First being
learning problems
and school dysfunction.
And so this is
not the same as an
intellectual
disability, because with
disability there's that
deficiency on both
their intellectual
ability and
functional skills.
Someone with a learning
disability has a
normal range of
intelligence, so a normal
IQ, but has isolated
academic skills
deficits and so their
academic performance
achievement on
standardized tests that
has an issue for
individuals with our
learning disorder the
scores on the tests
are substantially
below that's what's
expected for their
age schooling or level
of intelligence and
again this is not
due to vision or hearing
problems or motor
disabilities or
environmental issues.
Again, non-intellectual
disability,
risk factors being most
commonly prematurity,
a family history,
and having preschool
developmental
problems. There's
also a very high
association with
a reading learning
disability and children
that had speech
and language
developmental issues.
So for learning
disorders, there's several
categories, each kind
of with their own
subcategory and
again these are like
that difficulty
learning and using
academic skills with
a normal intelligence
and so for reading
learning disability it's
the most common type
of learning disability
or learning disorder
80% of learning disorders
are in the reading
category and it's
estimated five to ten
percent of the general
population has a reading
learning disorder so
word reading or think
more of dyslexia have
an issue of interpreting
the words that they
are seeing, having
issues with word
recognition and decoding,
or a comprehensive,
and so understanding
the meaning of
what is read.
These symptoms
must be present for
at least six
months despite for
interventions or
adjustments being made.
And these difficulties
during school-aid
years might not
really come to light
early on because that
person can compensate
for them. So it might
take time before
you figure out
they're having issues.
And again, these
difficulties are not
accounted for
an intellectual
disability, hearing
or vision issue,
inadequate educational
instruction, and
the other areas,
writing or math,
all of these being
very specific to
that academic skill
that they're having
difficulty in.
The normal presentation
of a learning disorder
is sometimes not
detected until very late,
because again, the
child can compensate.
They might memorize
words rather
than really learn
them, and it won't
be until later
grades when they get
challenged more
or have more work
that you'll
figure out they
have a learning
disability.
and commonly they'll
just start having issues
at school it's boring
that now they are
joking and goofing
around in class or the
opposite they have to
now start spending a
lot more time at home
doing their homework
and it's starting to
catch up and they run
out of time this then
leads to now I have
failing grades or I don't
want to go to school
or I'm starting to
act out and get in
trouble and now the goal
for the pediatrician
is to detect this early
intervene early try
to stop your behaviors
at this increased
learning effort or the
school distress because
if not it leads to
the school failure
now they're having to
be held back a grade or
they're getting
suspended or expelled
because of their
behavior and so trying to
prevent that they're
trying to catch it early.
As you walk through,
again, just like all
these other ones, history
is really key. This
is a little different
history than normal,
though, because we're
trying to now look
at the school and their
learning. And so from
a school history
standpoint, how are their
grades? What are their
teacher concerns?
How did they do last
year versus this
year? What's more
difficult than other.
What's their classroom
setting like?
Are there a lot of
students or they're
not? Have they ever
received IQ testing
or any other
therapies in the past?
And do they have an
IEP plan in place?
What's their school
day schedule? What
time do they get up
and go to sleep? Are
they getting adequate
sleep every night?
How long is their
homework taking them?
What are their activities
are they doing.
It can give a lot
of insight into
where the difficulties
are occurring.
How's their development?
Did they meet
all their milestones
at appropriate
time? Did they meet
any other therapies?
The social history.
It can really show too
if this is specific
to just learning or if
it's other areas of
their life that are
being affected. Did they
make friends easily?
Do they play in
other activities? How
are their relationships
with their parents?
And still obtaining
a good pregnancy
and past medical
history. Are they
in utero exposures?
Are they *********?
Do they have any
sensory deficits?
And a family
history, any family
problems with
other learning
disorders or
school problems.
In this workup is
very multidisciplinary
and so covering both
physical exam, diagnostic
testing, and
psychoeducational testing.
The physical
exam, there's no
physical exam finding
is pathognomonic
for a learning
disability.
You're trying to look
to make sure again
that there's no
other underlying
syndrome and disorder.
So any dysmorphia,
skin lesions, a normal
neurologic exam.
From the diagnostic
standpoint,
again every
child's vision and
hearing should
be assessed.
And only neuroimaging
and genetic
testing, if there's
concerns based on
your history and
physical and without
a specific concern
or indication
usually these are
not that helpful or
indicated and so
then you get to the
psychoeducational
testing now that's
beyond the scope
of a pediatrician and
usually that's the
school or a psychologist
that will help
perform both cognitive
assessment and
achievement testing the
testing for the learning
this disability
involves evaluation of
both components the
cognitive so you you're
looking at the
intellectual disability and
achievement testing
academic performance
and accomplishing this
again it's the whole
team it's the physician
the audiologist
the psychologist the
teacher any of the
therapists my main
role is to again rule
out hearing vision
making sure there's no
other disorders or
syndromes that could
be contributing to their
symptoms and getting
them to the right
person to help them
The long-term management
is very complex.
My goal is to be an
advocate for them, to
make sure that the
teacher is listening, to
make sure that they're
getting therapy and
receiving services at
school, to make sure
that I'm a medical home,
that I'm continuing
to assess for other
functional or mental
health problems. I can
help them review their
individualized education
program to make
sure the school is
doing what they should,
and being there to
continue to monitor for
behavioral and
developmental surveillance.
So now pivoting off
of learning disorders
and learning
disabilities and now
going to behavior
problems. I'm going
to focus on two main
behavior problems,
so oppositional
defiant disorder, ODD,
and conduct disorder.
So that's CD.
And so for oppositional
defiant disorder,
that's a pattern of
behavior above what is
typically expected of
defiance. And so These
symptoms are
commonly trouble with
authority, breaking
rules, very argumentative,
non-compliant.
Commonly, it's before
the age of 8, no later
of a presentation than
early adolescence.
Again, these
symptoms have been
present for at
least 6 months.
In comparison to
conduct disorder,
sometimes there's
child onset, so before
the age of 10, or
adolescent onset.
That's either after
10, and rarely is it
after 16 that you'll
have an onset. But
for Conduct
Disorder, this is now
aggression towards
others, towards animals.
You get destruction
of property,
setting fires,
breaking laws,
breaking serious rules.
And commonly, this
is, again, been going
on for at least six
months, but three
or more incidents
over the past year.
And more commonly,
this occurs in males,
so 6-16% of males
versus 2-9% of
females will have
some sort of behavior
disorder. Risk factors
including kind of
neglect, psychological
mistreatment,
being witness to
domestic violence, or
parents disciplining
that was physical.
Important to understand
the comorbidity of
these behavior
disorders with other
conditions. And so
commonly being associated
with ADHD, the learning
disorders, anxiety,
along with decreased
IQ, language deficit,
along with a common
association to
psychosocial stressors.
And that's an
important one to
kind of pull out to
make sure, A, that
you're asking the
right questions
with your history.
When all of this
started, did anything
particularly happen?
Was there a loss in the
family? Was there a
big dynamic change?
and so that's where
and that history
being very important
characteristics of
the behavior how often
is it where is it
occurring does
anything trigger it and
then making sure we
consider the child's
development hey are
they developmentally
where they should
be are they having
delays or significant
impacts that
could be contributing
to their outburst
also important
to look at the
temperament of the
child and the parents
how is their
relationship how do they
get along with one
another how are their
interactions are
there any other social
stressors going on
and then also that
impact on functioning
and academics
this history is coming
from a lot of people
not just the patient
not just the parents
that's where you're
looking at teachers
and getting more
information and so
that's what gets
you into your workup
being both a
parent interview,
the child interview,
or teacher interview.
That overall goal is
just to establish,
are the behaviors
normal for their
developmental
stage, or does it
really represent a
behavioral disorder?
Those that are
normal for their age
are usually short
-lived and not causing
significant or
persistent issues.
The ones that continue,
so now they're
lasting for more than
six months, or it's
been over a year
of constant issues,
That's where
we're starting
to get into
these disorders.
And so there's a
couple rating scales,
whether it's the
Connors or the Child
Behavior Checklist.
These can help give
some of that
objective information.
Your history from
your parent or from
a teacher can be
very subjective.
Maybe they have a
bad relationship, but
these rating scales
can give very
objective, specific
information. And so they
can be sometimes very
helpful. I wouldn't
worry about memorizing
which of these
they are and what
questions they ask.
Now getting into
the treatment
of behavioral problems.
And so parent behavior
management, which
is something we'll hit
on in ADHD as well,
but that's working
with the parent. It
teaches techniques
and strategies to help
with the child's
behavior, reinforcing
good behaviors, working
through instruction
or critiques of
what their child is
doing and using
appropriate consequences.
So how do they work?
The biggest thing
is having that
consistency, very
important with parent
behavior management.
You can also do
cognitive behavior
management, and
so that's working
with a team to take
kind of a step-by
-step approach to
solving problems.
Now, medication
sometimes is indicated,
and that's an
adjunct to behavioral
therapies for severely
aggressive behaviors.
And now this would
be a psychiatrist
helping, working with
the team to work with
that patient. For
example, sometimes ADHD
is using stimulants,
and there maybe is a
better medication for
them that would help
with both their
conduct and their ADHD.
And so working
as a team to see
if there is any
medication that
can help with
their behaviors.
So we're going
to come back to
our patient two
as we wrap up.
This was our seven
-year-old male in
second grade having
learning issues.
We're getting
C's and D's,
maybe going to
need to repeat a
lot of social
stressors recently.
It's tricky because
I don't know if
we answered enough
questions. I didn't
take a good enough
history. I think
we kind of need some
more information.
We're going to
look into ADHD,
we're going to look into
learning disability,
but I think that we
need more history
because that's
going to be the main
component as you
break down these
learning disabilities
and school
problems that a
child's having.
Again, here is our
assessment objectives.
We covered a lot
of information.
And here's a super
brief summary slide.
I think the main
thing to know is
that normal child
development is
very a wide range,
super variable.
Delays can occur in
any developmental
domain and it's
really important to
monitor closely
for developmental
delays for
neurodevelopmental disorders
because early
intervention is key.
Always consider a
broad differential
diagnosis and the
comorbid conditions.
A thorough history is
key to helping with
your differential
and to help with your
diagnosis and constantly
providing that
support and education
for parents and
being that medical
home is very important
here are some
references and again
here's my email and a
lecture feedback form
we covered a lot of
information please
reach out if you have
any questions and
there's some good
articles and resources
on the CPG but again if
you have any questions
reach out and thank
you for your time